the trial judge said code is speech now
what happened was basically the
government backed down encryption was
literally deemed a weapon ammunition
yeah and therefore they said you are
exporting weaponry right code is not
just speech it has conduct elements to
it right this is like the holy ghostman
argument the plans are not the gun the
plans for a bomb and the plans for the
lower receiver of a weapon still are
protected the government gets to draw
lines on how much usage is elicit before
they're going to regulate the speech
again it gives me hope because we have
tools like bitcoin that do provide
financial freedom if i was a government
official and i was hell-bent on just
completely stomping out bitcoin could
they do what they did to tornado cash
and just say the entire bitcoin
blockchain is now on the ofac list
theoretically they could all right guys
bang bang i've got aaron here with me uh
i'm very excited about this because uh
it seems like a huge debate in society
that uh has happened in the past but is
resurfacing is this idea of software
being uh free speech and uh being
protected by the first amendment uh you
have a specialty in understanding a lot
of this uh but i thought a great place
to start would be the
kind of quintessential um legal case of
bernstein versus the department of
justice which really set the precedent
for code being
free speech
help us understand like what should
people know about that specific case
that really laid the precedent for you
know some of the things that are
happening yeah so it's so it's it's
really interesting and i i didn't know
as much about it until recently and i
started going back and researching you
know the crypto wars of the 90s and the
you know formation of the cypherpunk
movement
and all this you know that's that's
where all this started and it's
interesting to know that the the
bernstein case bernstein was a professor
um and had basically created an
algorithm right uh encryption and
decryption algorithms and and also had
an academic paper on it and wanted to
publish the paper and you know publish
the the algorithm you know this was his
you know he worked on it as a graduate
student and wanted to put the
information out there and teach on it
and so at the time you had these really
strict um
export
regulations you know cryptography was
classified as like a munition so you had
to get permission
pre-permission from the government at
the time it was state department and
then it shifted during the litigation it
was moved to different departments and
things like that but you had to get
pre-permission to essentially export
these munitions you know encryption
algorithms right and so he sued the
department of state um to get permission
to do well if he sought permission they
denied it
within their boundless discretion which
then became really important to the
decision because
um the trial judge judge patel in
northern district california
said
first there there were actually a series
of
orders that she issued the first was
code is speech and that's what everybody
thinks of when they think of bernstein
is you know the source code is speech
then the next
order was summary judgment in favor of
bernstein because this
scheme of boundless discretion within
you know
an agency
of determining whether or not to license
the speech it just violates the first
amendment there's got to be you know you
can have
time place manner restrictions on speech
right um
noise ordinance stuff right yep
but it's got to be there's also got to
be you know really strict judicial
review um and
a method and a process for
reviewing
the discretion of the agency that's
licensing speech basically so that was
the first part of it
now what happened was and this is what i
didn't realize either until until i
started looking into it more deeply
that's a trial those are trial court
orders okay in terms of like order of
presidential value
um
those are pretty low compared to
something like the supreme court case
which would be the highest president in
the land every single court has to
follow it even the state courts and
you've got the intermediate appellate
courts um and in this case it was out in
california so it was the ninth circuit
court of appeal
the ninth circuit did issue an opinion
affirming
but what happened was the government
asked for rehearing
which means we're hearing on bonk which
means you get most of the judges
together instead of a three-judge panel
really big decision um and you know
get all of the the judges to weigh in
on on the court so they rescinded
the ninth circuit rescinded the
affirmance of of the code of speech you
know orders
and then
never got around to issuing an onboard
opinion because in the interim
um basically the government backed down
on so brian basically said hey i'm going
to release this uh
code the source code along with a white
paper essentially
and it was related to uh encryption yes
at the time encryption was literally
deemed a weapon ammunition yeah uh and
therefore they said you are exporting
weaponry right uh even those words in a
database um and he said no i'm not i am
speaking exactly
words
and so they went to court as these
things tend to do yeah uh one just like
how about the balls on bernstein go
against the united states government
around weaponry or words it's it is
yeah it it talk bernstein all of these
you know the cypherpunks
and folks who are cypherpuck adjacent
like zimmerman who created pgp like
zimmerman you know went not only against
like the government and nsa and stuff
like he went against like the patent
holders of these encryption algorithms
public key private key encryption
algorithms rsa was the company that had
a lot of the patents and we could get
into you know how a lot of people think
that you know also delayed the public's
use of encryption because you not only
had the nsa
trying to you know in the state
department preventing you know private
use of encryption but then you also had
patent holders who had the most powerful
you know encryption products you know
as as and it was the thought process
that encryption essentially allowed for
uh their use cases but they didn't see
the use case for like the individual to
have privacy oh no they saw the use case
exactly it was it was that the trade-off
you know privacy
to the nsa and the government was
you know
a sacrifice they were willing to make
you know on behalf of the american
people to keep people safe
right that was the idea is that we can't
let terrorists and arms dealers and you
know foreign adversaries
have this you know important
shielding technology to shield
communications because then it's going
to make america less less safe
and so as bernstein went to court wins
kind of the court case there's these two
distinct and different uh um kind of
judgments if you will or outcomes uh one
code is speech and two you as the us
government can't just say like we make
up the rules as we go
uh
why did the government back down in some
of the appeals process or eventually not
take it to the supreme court or whatever
yeah i mean what happened was
um
bernstein essentially lost his his
standing
um and the issue became not ripe was one
of the final final rulings uh in that in
that saga because the government
essentially just let him
just said hey we're not going to win
into some degree so rather than it was
catch the l yeah it was probably a
strategic decision yeah and so then what
you had you had two other decisions
that were subsequent to bernstein
um one from the sixth circuit court of
appeals called junger and junger was
also almost the same fact pattern as as
bernstein he was a case western
professor who had you know algorithms
and papers he wanted to publish
and ran the same playbook um
and that actually did get an opinion
code of speech
now the problem was it was much more
limited
and kind of problematic and i think this
is a nuance that a lot of people are
missing
today in the discussion about code being
speech and you know first amendment
rights protecting
code
the junger court said
code is not just speech it has conduct
elements to it okay right
you run you you you've got source code
which is speech but then you also
run the source code through a compiler
and click a button and now your program
you know just decrypted dvds or whatever
it is
so there's a conduct element to it that
you know the person who's receiving and
running the software isn't reading the
source code it's not communicative it's
it's conduct and so
the government junger said should be
able to lo should be able to
regulate the functions
of code if they're doing it in a way
that is content neutral as to the speech
so so is this like when you get into
like the ghost gun stuff where it's oh
yeah that's the
the code
for or like the plans of the ghost gun
itself are protected by the first
amendment right but then if i download
it and i go and i create a 3d printed
gun that would be more of this idea of
like the functional component yeah this
conduct and function and then so then
yeah so we'll put a pin in that we'll
come back to that um
the other case was um in the second
circuit which is overseas new york and
so they get a lot of you know the
financial
type litigation but this was um
universal studios
brought an action not under the export
laws but under um dmca
which we're all familiar with you know
the strikes and takedowns and stuff but
there's actually a provision in dmca
that says circumvention technology
technology that's designed to circumvent
digital rights management
encryption that you know prevents you
from playing a japanese dvd on an
american dvd player
that technology was you could the
government could get injunctions to
enjoy in publishing that circumvention
technology that's circumventing
you know rights copyrights and things
like that
um and so
i don't know if you ever read the 2600
magazine it was like a hacker hacker
quarterly 2600 magazine it was a little
like 10 inch
you know pamphlet magazine in high
school i got it
you know i'd go find it and felt like i
was you know
like on the edge like you know live in
the cypherpunk dream because i was
reading about i you know i i barely knew
how to code i was just you know
messing around with computers and stuff
in high school but um
the publisher the editor of 2600 was
publishing
dvd decryption algorithms got it he
didn't write them but he was publishing
the code and publishing links to the
code
um on 2600's website and universal
studios came in and sued him to get an
injunction to stop that decryption
software from getting out and the second
circuit said the same thing as junger is
that there's this functional component
to code
and so if the government is going to
regulate the functional components um
without you know obviously regulating
the speech elements and saying what you
can and can't necessarily what is the
difference right yeah it's it's a
difficult distinction to bring up there
the function was
you know
essentially circumventing copyright
regimes so you can have the code you can
you can click on it you can look the
code yeah you can look at the code there
i think that the actual
um
ruling was you know they couldn't 2600
couldn't link out to it um
and disseminate it that way
um
but it gets
there's not much of a distinction let's
put it that way yeah the bernstein
decision judge patel's decision was the
more
principled i think
because
what the younger
court and the
corley court were saying
was that
the functional aspects we're going to
use these tests
to analyze whether or not the functional
aspects can be regulated we're going to
use these tests that came out of like
the flag burning and the draft card
burning cases which
is
which the judge patel also looked at and
analyzed that argument and rejected it
and said
you know regulating flag burning and
nude dancing is so totally different
from regulating source code
it
the analogy just doesn't just doesn't
fit because you know and this is
something that um
peter van valkenberg at coin center has
written on too um
and he also agrees you know with with
judge patel's reasoning um which is
which is that code code is pure speech
yeah and they're sure there's some
conduct elements to it
but it is a medium of speech
yeah you write words right in a database
right and so if they are going to say
you can uh
tweet
or you can write on paper or you can
write into a database
it seems in today's day and age that
that is all speech and is protected
where we get into this weird world is
and really kind of the conduct component
i think a modern day example is this
idea of tornado cash yeah where uh my
you know elementary view or the way that
i would describe it to somebody is uh an
engineer went wrote code that code
allows for people to use it and do
things with it uh
and
there's a lot of people who say hey
that's protected by the first amendment
of the united states right uh
because code is speech
maybe it's not as black and white it's
not as black and white unfortunately
you know if if uh
right so that so we're stuck with the
corley and the younger you know
functional
distinction with code um
and so that's where
tornado cache now there's a lot of
different issues with tornado cap okay
so
we can peel it apart but that is that is
where
that is where there's wiggle room
for the government
to regulate code in certain ways so
tornado cache for those i don't know is
a mixer which uh at the most basic sense
uh allows you to uh take
the information on the blockchain uh the
sender
is very clearly able to track uh funds
from sender to receiver right is the
whole idea of a blockchain everything's
transparent yeah everything's written
there it's immutable it can't be changed
a mixer uh in the most basic form says
uh
the information or the value of the
transaction from the sender to the
receiver is now not as easily trackable
right and the way that that's done is uh
you can send
economic value into the mixer yeah mixes
your funds with somebody else's or many
other peoples and then the output is uh
appears to be random to somebody looking
at this but you're able to direct it as
the sender right and the recipient still
receives the value that you want them to
receive
uh
walk us through like the analysis of uh
software is speech yeah
but it sounds like the government uh
drastically disagrees we've now seen
them uh invoke ofac uh there's been a
developer who was arrested
how do you look at a situation like this
yeah so the so
i guess let's just reset
where what happened with tornado cash
and and ofac is the office of uh
foreign asset control there that's the
department of treasury that
you know hunts terrorist funds basically
and money launderer funds and tries to
you know
stamp stamp that you know tamp that back
down
um and so they have a list of you know
specially designated nationals
has to be foreigners can't be americans
okay and um if if someone's put on that
list or someone's bank accounts are on
that list
americans are on notice they cannot
transact so americans can't be put on
the list correct but if you're an
american and you transact with or you
can be liable yes under the regime um
there's like civil penalties there's
also some criminal penalties i'm not
this is not an area of law compliance is
not my area of law but i'm you know i've
been following along um and then holiday
exactly i slept in a holiday inn last
night down the street and uh you know
it's all good so um so ofac though
um is as far as i understand it
is authorized by its authorizing statute
to
add
entities
and individuals to that list okay that
sdn list of sanctioned uh the sanctions
list
and then the essentially you know
account aliases of those individuals and
those entities okay so let's talk about
what happened with tornado cash tornado
cash
[Music]
tornado cash you know scare quotes is
what was the first entry on the list
and then
the website
okay let's let's for purposes of the
discussion just assume there is an
entity a group of people
called tornado cash sure okay call it
you know people like to get into like
well it's a dao and it's not a real
entity because it doesn't have legal
rights it's like well
dows are all kind of general
partnerships
under most state laws like if people get
together or joint ventures if people you
know you and i get together and you know
it's kind of like a contract is if you
and i can have a verbal contract even if
we didn't pay for it if we you and i
start working against unincorporated
entities yes yeah yeah we can have you
know full liability okay for for our
enterprise that we start working on so
but but so let's just say tornado cache
is an entity sure um you know the
website being
added to the list you know i guess
that's the front end so you know you
can't go in and transact through that
front end if you're an american and then
there's this list of ethereum addresses
on the blockchain
i didn't understand this at first
because i'm i'm not really steeped in
you know how ethereum works i mean i
know it's smart contracts and during
complete and all that stuff and
um but
some of those addresses
were
like donation addresses for the project
and so presumably there's like an admin
key that someone holds and there's some
control or the dow holds or something
there's control over those
others though we're just
the address where those where the smart
contract of the mixer exists right where
you when you call on the contract at
that address that's where that's where
you send your funds that's how the mixer
works it it would be like
listing
you know
the cal berkeley server
where bernstein's algorithm was got it
got it right it's that's that's
essentially what happened now
where
where we get into whether or not that
was authorized is well is that property
of
tornado cash like they don't have the
they can't change that code now it's
like you said it's immutable and it's on
the blockchain
right this is very similar to like
uniswap has the front end yeah which is
controlled by the unisoft entity and
they have made changes they have
responded to regulation
but uh
theoretically the uniswap smart contract
cannot be
changed shut down et cetera and there's
you know i don't know 50 to 100 other
interfaces exactly leverage that you
know almost back end right yeah the
front end you can point to whichever
smart contracts you know you want yeah
but you know if someone knows the
address of the previous smart contracts
they can just go access those
smart contracts just like just like you
know
you change the links on your websites
but you know if you don't take down the
original you know page you can and you
remember the link you can go access it
so
let's go through this part by part so
tornado cache uh there's a a group of
individuals right the
[Music]
list that organization to be based on
your analysis and maybe others that i've
seen uh well within what normally would
have been expected by ofac yeah okay
exactly then there are what i'll call
those individuals accounts which is
equivalent although different but but
equivalent to their bank accounts in the
legislative financial system and so if
the people or the group is going to be
put on the list then you would expect
the their accounts to be put right and
the analogy
this happened recently with blinder.io
which was another mixer that was
custodial
meaning you know you said they had on
they had a lot more you know yeah
contact with the actual users who were
using it um and were just taking it in
and then remitting out you know they had
a lot more discretion over what was
going on it was the same
these announcements and the listings
mirrored each other
um and in the blender dot io there were
bitcoin addresses that were listed
and
the entity that ran blender.io
presumably had you know the the private
keys
so
let's stop right here for one second
these are a couple of questions just at
like the highest level around uh the us
government stepping in and saying you
know
no moss right this is not good um
their
argument uh from what i read is that uh
there's north korean hackers right who
were able to uh launder funds using
these products or this technology
uh and that was really the impetus for
why the government was stepping in and
saying hey this isn't allowed if
that was not the case let's say that
there was no trace of north korean
hackers using the technology
it is unclear whether they would step in
and say you cannot use this you cannot
do this um
there's a lot of people who would argue
no they were just looking for a reason
to step in and shut this stuff down
there's other people who argue no it's
good faith they are only trying to stop
it because north korean hackers you and
i aren't going to get to the bottom of
that
[Music]
but but it does bring the question of uh
it appears that the north korean hacker
argument uh is true and rather than
debate the accuracy of it let's just
hold that as true
now
the counter argument is
well wells fargo and jp morgan and ubs
they seem to be doing a lot of you know
uh
uh complicit activities that help people
launder money whether they know it or
not
it over and over and over again we see
from mexican cartels to terrorists to
you know whoever there's money going
through those organizations but we don't
see the same heavy-handed approach
there's fine sometimes there's whatever
there are a lot of fines uh i i mean
like hsbc i think hit with they're
probably the big one yeah they're the
big one um and that was and that was it
was pretty
pretty impactful i think for that bank
um and you know
i think the
the distinction that some would make
is that
well yes but all of these banks have
very robust compliance regimes
departments
anti-money laundering protocols
um and they're so long as they're making
you know the good faith effort
um
and they're checking all the boxes on
the compliance checklist then that's
different than what we have here because
one we have
a group that's not doing that now i
think they did start to make some
efforts at one point the tornado cache
entities to um screen ofac
uh sanctioned addresses
um which feels like at the most
elementary level like that's like a
pretty simple
uh okay
fine will prevent the o facts thing
right
addresses from interacting with yeah we
can yeah we can have a debate about
whether or not you know
your privacy tools should be
should be uh accessing blacklists uh
but but yes so so they were attempting
to do this but at the same time you know
the other distinction is will banks
you know have a
social economic purpose
um
you know extend credit and you know just
allow the economy to grow at a much
faster rate than you know barter
uh et cetera et cetera basically that
argument is like uh yes they're being
treated differently but there's a reason
there's a reason why right and and
because this because tornado cash the
purpose for tornado cash is a privacy
enhancing tool
right some would say it's a money
laundering tool no no it's a privacy
enhancing tool and money launderers have
used
privacy-enhancing aspects of it to their
benefit into the detriment of national
security and this goes back to the whole
encryption debate of uh you and i can
message on uh you know i'll use whatsapp
as the example many people who'll pay
the encryption there uh but if we are
communicating it's not because we
necessarily are hiding anything it's
actually we just want the privacy to be
able to communicate without you know
worrying about people hacking or
communications or whatever uh but the
argument previously had been
no this is only going or bad people will
use it right and so just because bad
people will use it doesn't mean that
good people shouldn't have the ability
to do it uh same thing with the bank
right right bad people will use it
doesn't mean good people shouldn't use
it right which then brings us to tornado
cash which is like if bad people use it
and it's good
and this is what a lot of people are
struggling with and i'm struggling with
it too is to figure out
where the line
is right because
if if we start from first principles and
say code is speech you have a first
amendment right
to code and to publish that code
then
there should be
very
few
uh you know prior restraints on your
ability to publish that code
um
again you can make these edge case
hypotheticals where you know you've got
you know dirty bomb plans and stuff like
that right
that are clear clear national security
importance that
um you know there might be some but
again
even in that case you know if you're
arguing from just first principles you
know this is
we're we're
we're still
there's there's some
social value to even
you know discussion publishing dirty
bomb plans right i mean this is amazing
to figure out how to defuse the dirty
bomb plan yes right this is like the
whole ghost gun argument right which is
like there's a lot of people who are
like hey we don't want unregistered guns
on the streets we don't want all this
stuff and then there's a whole other
group of people who say
the plans are not the gun
and
even if the plans increase the
likelihood that somebody will create a
quote-unquote gun uh but actually it's
the receiver it's not the full gun like
there's all this nuance to that debate
that we don't need to get into uh
the plans for a bomb and the plans for
the lower receiver of a weapon um
still are protected right to some degree
right in the game some degree but you
know if you're publishing it with an
explicit call everyone go make bombs and
you know go blow up buildings and then
you're inciting violence and then that's
not protected by the first amendment
correct so there's context that goes
into uh if you just publish something
versus if you alongside say right go
inside violence okay that's a little bit
different
but with the tornado cash
specific example from again
i've read enough about it to understand
it was always just you can use this to
enhance your privacy it was not a call
to hey every terrorist criminal money
launderer in the world come use our tool
because like it's a free-for-all yeah as
far as we know it publicly that's what's
going on you know who knows who
literally who knows what's going on
behind the scenes the details would
change if all of a sudden the developers
of nato cash were emailing based on all
the assumptions we have now yeah and the
publicly available information we have
now yeah that's true and so
yeah you get into this
because of where we are in our first
amendment precedent with
functional aspects of code allowing
incidental regulation of the speech
elements
it
it is now
the government
gets to draw lines
on how much usage is elicit
before they're going to
regulate the speech
um so
literally a percentage amount like if
one percent
this is obviously not the like the law
right and this is not like the doctrine
but this is functionally i think a way
to this is a heuristic to look at it
right it's a mental model to look at it
you know there was about 10 i mean it
was 12 percent that was flagged
uh of funds that went through tornado
cash that was ransomware
derived
half of the funds were defi where flag
was just defy funds right
so
you know when you look at the
percentages of licit versus illicit use
and then i forget what the other
categories were you know the
the overwhelming amount was just general
trade and commerce
right
um some would say speculation
but that's also trading commerce okay um
so
in that case the government stepped in
um which is almost like you're you're uh
hinting at because we don't know the
answer but like let's say the government
had an unofficial role that once it
crosses over ten percent once we hit
double digits of illicit you know users
yeah now we will step in right but if it
had stayed at 9.5 maybe they wouldn't
have spent it's and it's
also it's like well is it percentage of
you know they were going by percentage
of funds that were flowing through but
percentage of users
you know the north korean hackers was
was much smaller percentage of users and
so that's where
you know neutral tools so you can say
tornado cache is a neutral
tool just allows privacy
um neutral tools can be used for good or
for
for bad um you know the internet is used
for good and bad um so
you know where you draw that line
is is the question and right now the
government has the pen and they get to
draw the line now is that a good thing
that the government has the pen yes um
the government's got to have the pin to
some degree um we do you know
if we want to live in a society that's
you know has a government that has a
government and and is safe and then
protecting you from you know foreign
aggression
what have you
um then you need to have a government
that is drawing lines somewhere
um
but
the way
how they use the pen it with respect to
tornado cache i
i think was outside their
their statutory ofac statutory mandate
because again they used they drew the
line by adding
just pure
unowned
code those addresses
that are on the ethereum blockchain
forever
were sanctioned
um
but the statute the authorizing statute
doesn't give ofac the ability to
sanction
unowned code so is this right this is
not intellectual property oh yeah
tornado cache this is unowned code is it
the equivalent of we said okay the you
know unincorporated organization right
or whatever the group of people okay
again we can debate whether they should
or shouldn't be there
[Music]
those people have accounts yeah and so
similar to the a bank account right
those get put on again whether or not
they should have been put on is
different than they are allowed to be
put on or there's precedent for being
put on uh this list but then you're
saying it's almost like uh
oh these individuals read a book one
time right and now they don't own the
book
uh
so we're gonna put the book on the list
and it's like wait a second like the
book is a neutral thing if you go to the
library and you pull the book then
you're going to be in violation yes
and that is uh where i think this first
amendment question comes in which is um
just because these people who you deemed
to be in violation of something and
again we'll debate you know whether
that's true or not uh they read this
book
now no one else can read the book
and
that seems to be where a lot of lawyers
are saying wait a second uh we may need
to have a deeper conversation exactly
yeah
how do you think that plays out yeah
it's difficult to
game out because again because it's code
that's not owned by anyone
you know going back to that question of
like standing who has the who's been
harmed and has the ability to bring a
suit to challenge these the this ofac
action it's it's difficult to
to identify anybody right
um so so teeing up a court case which i
know coin center is trying to do
is really difficult
there there's some argument
to be had
that
americans
who used tornado cash and deposited into
tornado cash and had not withdrawn
funds from tornado cash and still have
their funds
locked in the protocol
and are now
presumably look i'm not giving anybody
legal advice
none of this is worried about
withdrawing that yes um
those folks might have a claim because
their funds have essentially been frozen
without prior like due process process
yeah without prior notice so that that's
an avenue that if somebody wanted to
challenge these
broader reg these this broader action
that would be you know i think that's a
strong
that would be a strong case so
from a non-lawyer um a lot of times
there's cases uh bernstein um seems a
little bit different but uh maybe in the
crypto world there's an individual i
believe he was in kentucky uh he was
taxed on i think staking yeah rewards
and
it was a pretty nominal amount i mean i
think it was yeah two or three thousand
dollars frankly um
but it was more of a principled fight
than it was the economically driven hey
this a lot of money uh and he's
continued to pursue that yeah there's a
lot of folks who are watching because
they're saying that's pretty interesting
that is an interesting case yeah um
it feels like here
yes jared versus the us or the irs yeah
it feels like here with a tornado cash
like there are probably people who have
material amounts of money locked up
whatever that is to them uh
but it does feel like there's almost
this like legal apparatus that is
somebody is going to pick up the flag
and take on this fight uh and it's more
of the principled
fight than it is
hey i sent ten thousand dollars and and
like you know that's my life savings
yeah no and but but you need but you do
need some
some harm yes to be able to bring a case
uh the first amendment is a little bit
first amendment challenges
it's a little bit easier that like harm
requirement is a little softer okay
because
um
the idea is you don't have to have
suffered a direct harm if there's an
argument that it's like over broad and
there's a chilling effect and it's
preventing the public from engaging in
that type of speech
then um
then your direct harm requirement is a
little there's a little more wiggle room
there okay so then let's go to uh maybe
the second step which was uh there's
this ofac uh uh list a bunch of stuff
gets put on it
i think there was kind of a shot across
the bow a little bit and the crypto
community is like oh [ __ ]
things just got ratcheted up you know a
couple notches
and of course uh there are people on the
internet who uh will take things into
their own hands and there's an
individual um who went and collected a
bunch of publicly known or kind of
doxxed addresses right it was like puma
and companies
shacks celebrities
well-known people in the crypto world i
mean this was very much like let me go
to
you know a whole list get a bunch of
these addresses and then they began to
withdraw very small amounts it was 0.01
east
into these publicly known addresses
so
at the most
kind of barbaric analysis
uh puma which is a legal you know a
corporation that would like to be in
good legal standing in the united states
of america and uh for everything that we
understand does not want to participate
in any sort of money laundering or
violation of those lists
they potentially
violated the ofac rest because they
uh received funds right that came from
a
entity slash software like sanctuary
piece of software yeah that was
sanctioned yeah now
i would imagine again you you will
correct me if i'm wrong here if they
went to court and said we didn't do this
right we didn't know it's the equivalent
of somebody sending me a wire right and
uh yeah i didn't ask them to do that i
just woke up one morning and it was
sitting there um
they probably won't get in trouble right
but i don't know
like wow that's where how do you realize
that that's where ofac is like serious
business because it's a strict liability
regime where like you don't the
government doesn't have to prove
intent
okay so explain this a little bit more
like and maybe let's use puma uh only
because they are an entity i don't want
to pull individuals
else sponsored by them
somebody else did this to you
but like as a corporation i think it's
it's different than an individual as
well where it's like they have legal
teams they have compliance like they
have shareholders like there's a lot of
complexity
how would you begin to analyze like is
puma potentially
liable for something here or do they
just go to court and say like hey guys
come on right well it would make sense
right i mean like practically speaking
ofac is not you know department of
justice is not going to bring an action
against
puma for you know unknowingly accepting
funds that came from tornado cash
but
um
[Music]
you know again so going back to the
strict liability right it they could
it doesn't matter it happened you
received the funds um
so so a um
legal
legal scholar he's practicing attorney
but i'll call him a legal scholar
because he predicted this a few years
ago really yeah andrew jinkus
attorney at k l gates um he he had he
had predicted that like
someone could he called it like a spray
attack right could just spray this
essentially tainted you know be it ether
you know bitcoins out and because right
ethereum and bitcoin and you know most
cryptocurrency you know that you don't
have to accept it just you know it just
shows up on the ledger as as being uh in
your address um so he he had uh
predicted this um and it's a big problem
it's a big problem because under the
letter of the law yeah there's there's
violations there um
and so it's just
it goes back to kind of that boundless
discretion of ofac right it's just up to
them now like how they're gonna treat
all this and let's say that they were
like no yeah you know [ __ ] you guys you
did this uh
and they wanted to enforce the letter of
the law what is the penalty well like
how bad could it be yeah i mean the
penalty can be jail time um
for for folks yeah it's real serious uh
probably it would be like fines um but
it can yeah it can be it can be jail
time there's criminal penalties um
but i think you know there's a process
and a procedure for like sequestering
funds that you suspect or you know
tainted and and you know flagging it
with ofac and things like that so i
think i'm sure pumas compliance folks
have you know checked all the boxes and
you know made sure to to quarantine
off any uh any tornado cashies well so
the reason i want to start with puma is
because they have all that
infrastructure shaq i do not think has a
full-fledged uh you know compliance team
and i know you might be surprised he's
he's pretty uh
he's a pretty big business so i'm going
to move from puma to shack to then to
whoever the average citizen yeah right
and i think that it's
it's at least expected that puma has
some sort of legal you know team and
compliance team etc shaq's maybe in the
middle maybe maybe not uh
the individual doesn't right and so
it almost goes back to this idea of like
the bangs right i remember reading this
article at one point
uh one of the things that the banks do
in order to uh kind of shield liability
or or at least uh again you could argue
whether it's good faith or it's kind of
cover your ass
uh if there are transactions that they
think could potentially be troublesome
right they basically just flag them but
the problem is that they're incentivized
for course yeah
activity reports yeah they are
incentivized to use these uh sars or
suspicious activity reports just do them
all right like at some degree like just
keep processing all the transactions and
then just you just say they're all
suspicious now again they don't do that
but they do a lot of them right and so
if it's here on the side of caution
let's put it that way yeah it's a very
uh politically correct way to say it's
the error on the side of caution uh and
again there's an argument as to like
maybe that's a good thing right
but then if somebody shows up later like
ofac or whoever and says uh hey that one
was problematic they say well we flagged
it like we thought it was suspicious
right and like we sent it to you guys
and you know whatever happened from
there happened the average individual
doesn't have that infrastructure doesn't
even know some of this stuff exists
exactly and you get into these problems
so i guess it becomes this weird thing
where like
now it's almost up to whether it's the
department of justice or somebody
do they want to
enforce the law or not and that fuel
like that kind of gray area feels like
again where some legal folks are
standing up and saying like let's have a
deeper conversation about it absolutely
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep good sleep is a game changer and
the eight sleep pod is the best sleep
machine i sleep on it every single night
a great night of sleep allows you to be
healthier be more arrested and have more
energy throughout the day and on the
brand new eight sleep pod three you can
sleep as cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit
or as hot as 110 degrees fahrenheit
that's the secret of thermoregulation
better sleep better energy get yourself
innate sleep you can go to
eightsleep.com pomp today to go ahead
and get 150 off your order 8sleep.com
not only do i sleep on it every night it
literally changed my life and i begged
the founders to let me invest in the
company
8sleep.com go get yourself an 8 sleep
pod and get a better night of sleep
yeah that's that's where it goes back to
you know there's got to be
especially when you're talking about
speech there's got to be some kind of
guidance on agency discretion when
they're licensing or you know preventing
speech of some type there's got to be
just you know
just protocols that they follow and then
there's got to be a clear method for
reviewing that now
on that point about a clear method to
review it someone whose funds are in
tornado cash there is a process
whereby you can apply for a license from
ofac
to remove funds or to to transact with
a sanctioned entity so there is a
process but again that's a post-facto
process um and when we're talking about
due process we're talking about you know
pre-notice yeah that's
that's the that's the gold standard of
due process so forget crypto for a
second if i don't you were on nofac list
right and i had previously had a
business relationship with you you had
some money uh i wanted to withdraw or
get that money back i could go and say
hey here's all the details will you
pre-approve me to do this transaction
i'm not trying to do anything nefarious
they approved yeah there's a process for
that got it okay um i can't imagine
they're handing out a lot of those
licenses at the moment
i can't imagine anybody would want to
dox themselves
to apply for one of those licenses so
this brings up uh another
fascinating point which is we have a
piece of software which we will hold the
assumption that it is decentralized no
one has control uh i do think that that
will come into question and and it will
be fascinating to see how decentralized
is it actually um
but
many of the addresses who have been
engaging with it or interfacing and
transacting are not like you know
anthony pompliano's wallet address right
it is a random string of letters and
numbers they're still anonymous yeah
and so
i do wonder how
far
will
legal organizations uh or government
organizations go to figure out who are
all those addresses yeah now they've
obviously done it for uh the ones that
they claim to be money laundering or
whatever um
but you know joe blow off the street who
put ten dollars in because he wanted to
test out the tool right is just a random
address today
because it now is on the ofac list do we
expect every single one of those
accounts they'll do the work to like doc
i don't think so i i don't think the
incentive is there for ofac or
department of justice to do that because
you know
again they they traced
the
you know the lazarus group i think that
was the north korean
groups they traced the money into
tornado cash right because that's
you got to start somewhere you can't you
can't really it would be difficult to i
mean i guess you could
i guess there are ways you could trace
it if you
you know you could map uh personally
identifiable in
information onto
um coins essentially or you know eth
that comes out of tornado cash after the
fact
um
but yeah i mean they they were they were
chasing
you know the money laundering funds and
the ransomware funds into the funds led
and so again because
you know i forget it was chain analysis
or one of those you know analytics firms
has has done the you know
done some heuristics and breakdowns and
said you know half of it is defy you
know presumably they know that there's
not really they know generally what type
of
you know activity was going on um
in tornado cache uh again they don't
know who was doing what necessarily all
the time but yeah i don't think the
incentive is there for doj to go after
every single user who's ever used
tornado cache but again these are now
we're having these conversations and and
we're having conversations again about
privacy enhancing tools
and it really all comes back to
do we have a right to anonymity
and would you analyze that right
so when you're talking about speech
the supreme court has said you have a a
right to anonymous speech
in certain circumstances like when you
are engaging in uh political assembly
um so actually and this is this is kind
of what what gives me a little bit of
hope about where we're going with with
uh you know the first amendment and code
and anonymity and privacy
um
[Music]
things last year a case uh called like
banta americans for prosperity versus
banta came out and the supreme court
invalidated
a california law or regulation
um that
uh
required disclosure of political donors
identity over like a certain amount
threshold oh interesting yeah
and uh it was like 5 000 or something
like that so like major donors
they
yeah all these packs had to like create
a list and like turn this list over to
like the california regulator who is you
know regulating you know
in
election
spending
um the supreme court struck that down
and you know
based in part on this line of cases that
you do have a right to anonymous speech
an anonymous assembly um which stems
from you know
our our rights to assemble and honestly
when we were creating this nation you
know for fear of you know being hung by
the by the british
right um
so it's it's it's a the right to
anonymity is like a deeply ingrained i
think american value
um
and it's only really in
you know recent times modern times where
that
the practical ability to maintain
anonymity has been rolled back
right
so
um so the supreme court is is is putting
out opinions
that respect and acknowledge that right
of speech
and even so this was in the context of
spending too right this was in the
context of um you know keeping
um keeping political donations anonymous
are electronic dollars like if i go to
the bank and i send you a wire is that
considered speech because it's software
is it considered speech because it's
software um like i'm not sending you
physical dollars right
that that is a metaphysical question
that has not been
resolved in the courts so this gets into
yeah this gets into um if if i was going
to give you a physical dollar that's
kind of like conduct yes but
it's also speech you know if i'm giving
you that money um
to to support your you know campaign for
mayor of miami or whatever i'll never
keep doing this thing yeah um
but you know i look i'm of the opinion
and not a lot of legal scholars agree
with this um but i think a lot of people
in the cryptocurrency and bitcoin uh
industry would agree with this is that
um
money and transacting
is
a form of speech it might be more
conduct
than speech but it transmits information
because what's that phrase like you know
don't tell me what you think show me
your investment portfolio right like
what do you value in life
you know where and
what is more expressive
than
me
showing you where i prefer to spend my
hard-earned you know time and effort
right money is just like the store of
all of your prior work and effort and
blood and sweat and tears
right so
when i show you
what i'm gonna spend that on
that that tells you a lot about me yeah
right i think that's i think there are a
lot of communicative elements
to transactions well i'll take you a
step further it's just like if money is
not in the analog form right it's on
physical money
and i send you a wire it's all software
yeah yeah i'm sending you words in a
database right and now sure they have uh
uh a purpose they have uh value assigned
to and they have all these different
things
but i communicated with the bank
literally i told the computer do this
the computer then sent you words yeah
your your bank accepted those words and
put them in a database for you to look
at later right and in some way uh
it's words yeah it is and
and it always go you know it
money
money also is like this this
this giant accounting system right it's
how society directs where to place uh
you know its efforts and its capital so
that we can progress
um
and so that it's a giant information
system all forms of money you know even
before even before you had um i heard
this this uh explanation of what credit
was the other day um from from a
podcaster and he was you know he
describes it as you know just at its
base level two cavemen
in the cave and you know you make fire
today i make fire tomorrow yep that's a
credit transaction
right speech
right that's speech that's not you know
there was some work
that occurred you know at different
times
um and there was value that was
exchanged
with you know the work that was done to
make the fire
but it was all
just speech yeah you know that credit
formation was just speech i'm not going
to take credit no pun intended for that
because it was really good it was uh um
the guy from the the crypto voices
podcast yeah he's very good yeah um if
we go back to the tornado cache uh
the next step in this kind of analysis
is you know so we have the ofac stuff
then we've got the like spray attack
yeah um
the one of the developers gets arrested
yeah in the not in the united states
[Music]
how do you analyze um the arrest itself
the fact that it didn't happen in the
u.s yeah i don't know if he was an
american citizen or not i do not
i do not know okay um
[Music]
yeah i don't know if he was a citizen
okay
but just the arrest in general
how do we understand um the legalities
of it or uh the precedent it sets yeah i
i mean it it it's a big chilling effect
it sets a huge precedent that
you know if you're if you're coding and
launching and publishing privacy
enhancing tools
that then
money launderers go and use that you
could be
liable i guess now again we don't know
all the facts behind that who knows
maybe maybe
you know i don't want to i don't want to
hope for criminality but i hope there's
more of a tie
uh than just the fact that
this guy in this group wrote this code
and and published this code
there's more details there are details
that could come out which we are not
privy to today i don't think anyone in
the public is uh that would drastically
change the analysis but given the
information we have right now it appears
that there's not
nefarious malicious conduct or anything
and that's why there's so many questions
yeah and it and it really has created a
chilling effect i mean
anyone who is an engineer and a software
developer
um
is scared i mean
they're scared and understandably so i
mean it's it is
you know it's like
it's like we're thrust back into the 90s
and you know you've got
big you know you've got goliath you've
got you know the government's coming
down on on developers um and that's a
that's a scary thing and um we as a
society shouldn't tolerate it we should
we should you know raise our voices and
say this is not
this is not uh consistent with our
values as a country and a nation and you
know not consistent with our
constitution um we don't want to live in
a society where anonymity is
criminalized
we want to live in a society where you
know privacy and anonymity
are
seen for what they are which is um
protection right protection from
uh you know those who might want to you
know
steal our identities you know steal our
funds
those who might want to harm us if we
have the wrong political opinion
um which thankfully in the u.s is not
you know always the case
certainly the government not is not
always trying to harm us uh because of
our political opinion
but uh in most of the world that's not
the case and so
we should be promoting these tools and
as a society and trying to reclaim our
our rights to to anonymous speech and
anonymous assembly and and the ability
to go throughout our lives
with the
um
authority and the autonomy and the power
to
choose what information we disclose to
others because that's what privacy is
you know there's been tons of
definitions of privacy over the years
and everyone struggles to understand
what it is just as brandeis wrote
a law review article back in like the
20s that was like the foundation for our
understanding of privacy where he said
it's the right to be left alone
it is but i think
the cypherpunks helped us realize that
privacy is really the right to let other
people know what you want them to know
and that you maintain control over your
information
and it's the con that control over your
information that is the key to
privacy um
it feels like um
the ofac list stuff
a lot of people
uh wow like that
surprised and shocked people
they arrested the developer i think
ratcheted it up even more um
and again we don't have all the details
uh
but
how do they draw the line in terms of
the privacy technology and i'll give you
maybe uh kind of different ends of the
spectrum so uh if i
was a software developer who worked at
uh i don't know coinbase a publicly
traded business then
for all intents and purposes follows the
rules you know has a compliance team
legal team
regulators have signed off it's in the
public markets and i am uh
creating technology that enhances the
privacy of our users to be able to
transact
and then you've got you know maybe
tornado cache on the other end of the
spectrum
not saying that either one is right or
wrong or whatever but just like
how do they think about like is it all
privacy technology is it just ones where
somebody does something bad uh
unfortunately i am sure
that somebody has used coinbase to do
something nefarious or wrong
um
it's like how do they think through that
or is it literally just a
uh kind of a group of people that get
together and they decide the severity
and then later on the courts figure out
whether it was the right decision or not
yeah i mean again i think it comes back
to
[Music]
you know the government
does have you know it doesn't have
boundless
uh resources we think we think it does
it has a lot
but they still do have to you know
department of justice and and ofac and
and
these these departments have to pick and
choose what they're gonna you know who
they're gonna go after
um
and so
again i think it just comes down to
the the most nefarious characters are
going to you know go down first
um
right right the low-hanging fruit um and
in the process
right there they're taking a swing at
privacy tools
um
if we had a third person here on the
podcast and they were from the
department of justice or from the
treasury or whatever what are some of
the questions that you would have to
better understand the situation like are
there things that you're like man these
are like the two or three open questions
right now that maybe it'll be decided in
court maybe we'll get more information
but these are the things that you're
most interested in learning more about
uh around this specific case yeah i mean
it would you know
first and foremost it would be
and this is the question we should all
be asking whenever there's any
government action anywhere state or
local or federal
what's your authority for this what
where where do you drive the power for
this action um like we were talking
about before uh so i would like to get
some understanding of
their thought process for putting these
um
[Music]
these these smart contracts that no one
owns on the list
whose property is that
are these aliases for someone
um
what what's the rationale behind that
because i think you know
perhaps there's not an understanding
from ofac uh of of the engineering
behind
uh
behind this system
um and maybe there is i i mean it's a
lot of smart people um
brings up the question of like again
decentralization like how decentralized
is it right we've heard from uh the
securities regulators and others um you
know uh was that uh dyno the the
technology decentralized
uh i think most people who have looked
at uh the tornado cash situation um
people way smarter than me who much more
technical and and read the code and
stuff uh they do believe that it has
legitimate claims to decentralization
right now you know decentralization does
a spectrum this whole thing of like is
it you know you need 10 nodes you need
50 nodes you need you know a certain
amount of people holding the keys lately
there's so many different ways you could
cut it um
but it does feel like a lot of people
think it changes and those are and those
are some questions that we could ask
right like what what is what is the
rubric internally that you're using to
determine you know control over this
this tool you're right admin keys or you
know however many developers are working
on it and you know who's who's directing
you know directing flow of funds you
know
the developers weren't directing the
flow of funds
through this protocol yeah so it's
fascinating to think about also because
um it begs the question that uh
one regulators governments uh
organizations that that have oversight
in various parts of uh economies
i think most of them and i've i've
talked to some of these individuals
everything from you know sec
commissioners to the cftc also
they're like look we got a pretty good
grasp of like some basic stuff
but we're figuring out along with
everybody else because guess what a
piece of technology that exists today
didn't exist two years ago yeah right
and like as this thing's getting built
the builders and investors are figuring
it out but also the regulators are kind
of running side by side trying to figure
it out and just naturally the innovators
will always be out in front and then the
regulars kind of catch up as they go so
i think anyone who analyzes stuff you
have to like one put in uh one part of
the conversation of like if you were the
regulator yeah would you have all the
information necessarily to make an
analysis some situations yes other
situations no and i think that's an
important distinction but the second
piece of it is uh
there's a lot of information
that we don't have in toronto cash
situation but many others where what's
being publicly presented
if you hold it at face value you come to
one analysis right and then we've later
found out
all sorts of different you know pieces
of data uh
then you're just like if i'd known that
other data point like my mind would have
completely you know changed and so i
think that there's a little bit of like
the fact-finding mission that some of
these uh bodies are going through of
just like how do we understand the full
playing field before we start making
decisions or frameworks or rubrics or
whatever
and i don't know if there's right
answers right like sometimes there is
definitely a right answer right and from
from the regulator's perspective and you
know ofac and doj's perspective like the
fbi's perspective if they wait you know
this would be the argument to let it all
play out and to have it figured out then
these tools are going to be in the hands
of every bad guy and every bad guy is
going to be using it and it's going to
be too you know it's too late
to do anything about it
and some of that is just
you know the answer to that is
we have to tolerate
some criminality in our society
um you can't uh you know look we've been
having
we've been having these debates you know
since the 90s but you know definitely
since 9 11 and the patriot act you know
americans have been struggling with
um the
trade-offs between safety and civil
liberties
and privacy um and this is just another
front in that continuing discussion or
battle if you want anything we're doing
in that balance now like would you give
us a a plus uh f minus like like
like
it obviously each situation is a little
bit different right like tsa and yeah
and all that people get all worked up
about but like
do we do a pretty good job do we do
compared to like other countries are we
actually like really shitty like how do
you think it um well if it's a
comparison game i think uh we're doing
okay
i would give us a c
okay just because i feel like um our our
you know ability to challenge actions in
the courts
um is still pretty strong
um
you know
as much you know we're talking about
free speech in the first amendment
it we still have a first amendment you
know it's still there and it exists and
we point to it and we can argue over it
and you know it is enforced um
that's not the case in a lot of the
world so i i
i feel good about that you know now
yeah i think
i think you know and this is just
since
the patriot act in 9 11
yeah we've gone backwards in our in our
you know rights and civil liberties and
our and our freedoms um and you know
again it was understandable at the time
the fear that the country felt and you
know but you know then we we you know
had too much of a a counter response
domestically um internationally as well
i mean it's just it's kind of wild
because
you know we're about the same age um and
so like
yeah exactly
um you know our our adult lives we've
been living in the glot in the global
war on terror right i mean it's it's
something that uh but but we're old
enough to have remembered like the
before times you know in the 90s and it
you know how it felt different
um even as kids i you know i
i just felt a little bit like freer um
in terms of
uh
i don't know
yeah airport exactly exactly exactly you
pick up somebody pick up your family at
the yeah you go back and watch seinfeld
or friends on netflix and you're you
just like it's a time capsule yeah and
you know it's it sometimes it it hurts
because you're like wow that was like
it wasn't all
it wasn't all bad like we didn't have
you know planes falling out of the sky
every every other day like
and this is you know this debate about
like safety and the trade-offs between
safety and civil liberties you know i
had a a german professor in in college
and uh
and this was you know early-ish in the
war on terror and and and uh everything
was still fresh and she was saying look
you know germany went through this
germany had a you know i guess in the
70s um series of you know terrorist
organizations and and um attacks and she
said look we had to we had to decide
like do we want to lock ourselves down
and live in fear um and give up all of
our liberties
for safety
or perceived safety i guess or are we
going to
you know hold our heads high and live
our lives without fear and and and
treating everybody with you know dignity
and respect and and keeping our rights
and you know she was of the opinion that
germany at the time had you know made
the right choice and and chose not to um
you know aggressively
shut society down
to combat terrorism and america went in
a different direction we did
and it's a shame but
again it gives me hope because we have
tools
uh like bitcoin
that do provide financial freedom um
then we have tools like cryptography and
you know those tools are enhancing our
safety and our you know through
anonymity um while at the same time they
can be used uh for ill but i think those
tools are in everyone's hands and and
and so we've we've got the ability to
keep moving forward uh and re reclaiming
freedom so uh
i met you because you're on peter
mccormick's podcast that's right yeah
shitty podcast book
i love peter
and you were talking about bitcoin in
what bitcoin
the first question that came to mind
when i saw the tornado cash stuff was
if i was a government official and i was
hell-bent on just completely stomping
out bitcoin
and i was based in america
could they do what they did to tornado
cash and just say the entire bitcoin
blockchain is now on the ofac list and
anyone who touches it i mean
theoretically they could right
theoretically they could i've never
heard anyone talk about no no
but
yeah the you and every other lawyer
would be lined up outside the court
ready to like have a field day
but
it does open up so it opens up this this
is this is an attack vector for any
any protocol and so every protocol and
all developers working on these systems
communication systems for transferring
value or just communication systems in
general
should be
rigorously
uh
testing
and and having really serious
conversations about whether or not their
technologies are sufficiently
decentralized to survive something like
that bitcoin will survive something like
that um it'd make it difficult for us in
the states to transact um but it would
survive
you know the technology and
infrastructure would survive the u.s
user
could be quote unquote frozen out right
right from uh from this
what it then brings into is this whole
thing like decentralization is really
freaking important it's really important
right um
but just because you have the
decentralization
that protects the protocol that protects
the the tech itself right
it doesn't necessarily
have the same impact on the individuals
because they are still subject to
individual citizens and this is where
you need base layer privacy um and base
layer anonymity and bitcoin's not
doesn't score great on that um there are
tools you can use
um that are similar to mixers but are
different um
coin joint tools and things like that
where you can
obscure and regain you know forward
anonymity in your transactions
um and those types of tools are
desperately needed because that's the
piece like you said
that's going to allow
individuals to continue to use a
decentralized network you know there are
privacy coins and privacy protocols that
have that built at the base layer and
they make different trade-offs that
bitcoins made
um
but that's the that's the key that's
that's what's needed is is privacy and
anonymity and and
the problem is is we live in this you
know bank secrecy act regime where
there's no your customer
regulations and
it's really hard
to
participate in these protocols
um
these cryptocurrency digital asset
protocols without going through
these kyc processes and these kyc gates
now like it's it's really difficult you
can do it
um but it's not user friendly
and that's where you know and i'm not an
engineer if i were that's what i'd be
working on i'd be working on you know
those privacy tools anonymity tools
that um
you know help us
and help individuals participate in
these in these protocols anonymously
um
you know when you think of bitcoin it
has the ability right and people
continue to build technologies to do a
whole bunch of things that i think the
bitcoin community is very excited about
one of the things you've looked at which
i find fascinating is bitcoin today in
its current form without having to be
built uh kind of further or continued
innovation
can really
i don't know mitigate some negative
externalities um
and one of the things that i saw that
you wrote that fascinated me is in many
legal cases
there is a judgment and if there are
financial penalties or fines uh through
a whole host of different actions the
court essentially can take the money
they can right freeze assets they can
confiscate it right out of somebody's
bank account uh the irs does this at uh
time to time somebody owes back taxes or
whatever
the idea of self-custody
changes the playing field there it does
yeah
how did that like how does that now
enter into the fray of just like
if they can't freeze your assets or they
can't confiscate your assets
does that level the playing field does
that ratchet up
their scrutiny of hey we don't like this
yeah so that's the bitcoin is a you know
seizure resistant it's not seizure proof
uh and censorship resistant
money
uh you know and uh if you self-custody
it
uh it's not like having a bank account
that can get frozen right if um
so what happens in the
how how it affects the legal system this
is something i've been thinking about
because this is what i probably what i
do is you know i
uh
work on litigation but i'm an appellate
attorney so i see the cases after
there's an order that needs to be
appealed and you know overturned or
upheld and then sometimes we get into
these like
post-judgment collection issues
and sometimes they're pre-judgment where
somebody is being forced to turn over
money before there's even a
determination of liability why would
they do that
so yeah exactly so this is this is very
important because in the united states
pre-judgment attachments are
um really hard to get they're frowned
upon
by the court system because if you have
your property and you haven't been
determined liable
it's still your property if ownership
hasn't been determined by the court
we're not going to take property that's
probably yours maybe yours maybe not but
it's in your possession possession's
nine tenths of the law gonna let you
keep that property until there's
determination that's not the case
in
a lot of countries so we saw this in
canada
with the trucker rally and you know
there was a big
movement a lot of donations through
bitcoin
to fund that political protest
and then there was actually a civil
class action lawsuit by like the ottawa
businesses who were who were you know
saying that they lost revenue from this
and they sued the organizers of the
trucker rally
and
one of the you know bitcoin for
for uh for the truckers organizers um
was a defendant and had to
turn over all the bitcoin that they
flagged as his
so that
you know it wouldn't be dissipated and
you know disappear before there could be
a collection so that's
that's the thing there's a flight risk
it is it's like it's like that
now in that case i mean this is
something called a mariva injunction
like the common law jurisdictions have
this it came from england canada has it
um i'm sure like australia and it's
spread out
um and it's used right to prevent uh
dissipating and shielding
capital that can eventually be used to
satisfy a money judgment which then you
know meets out justice between the
parties i don't know how important the
distinction is i feel like i'm going to
get a a law degree here
um
is it different than freezing assets
like i think of freezing assets it's
like it's in your bank account and they
say hey you're not allowed to move it
and maybe the bank helps them or
whatever this sounds more like
you we're scared you're gonna move it or
or we think there's a threat that you're
gonna move it give it to us yeah i think
in that case
um
i think in that case perhaps
it would have had to been transferred
because the nature of bitcoin is like if
you remember your seed phrase like yeah
you could give you could give them you
know your wallets or whatever but then
you know you just go right spin up
another wallet with your seed phrase and
move it so they probably yeah the
authorities prob somebody had to take
custody
of it but usually when you're talking
about bank accounts
right it's just a freeze
and
and this is this is where
you know this is the difference between
bitcoin and the traditional financial
system when it comes to money judgments
you know all of our financial system is
built on intermediaries and banks
custodians
and bitcoin allows for self custody and
disintermediates
and the way that money judgments are
executed and collected
is risk of garnishment on those
third-party custodians you have a bank
account
you know i tag you with a
judgment because whatever you hit me
with your car you know simple tort claim
or whatever and you owe me money
and you know you don't pay it
so then i get a writ of garnishment from
the court and it's served on your bank
and your bank says
that's a valid writ and here's the money
i'm going to remit it to you mr
plaintiff
um
with a bitcoin system where everyone's
holding their own keys and has their own
you know
their own wallets
there's no one to serve that rid of
garnishment on to collect from
so now
right the question is what do courts do
about that um you know let's
obviously right now it's not a huge
issue
but if we're like in a talk in like a
hyper bitcoinized world you know and and
intermediaries are gone
you know what what do the courts do and
and you know i think the tools they have
available are these pre-judgment type
attacks
where you know maybe if they know
that an individual
has funds because you know they have kyc
funds and all of their information is on
the blockchain and they can you know
follow the funds around
they can then
get orders to freeze that money now
again
i have the keys
so who's going to freeze it
that's where the second piece comes in
where the courts have contempt powers
where they can hold individuals in
contempt and put them in jail
for not complying with court orders so
then if i get an order to turn over my
private keys and i refuse
and the only place they are in my head
and the only recourse left for the
courts is to start imprisoning people
and now i literally have the key to the
jail cell in my head
this brings an even kind of more complex
piece of uh everyone that i know who has
done any self-custody right uh when they
first started like i've forgotten things
right or i lost something or i sent
whatever right um and you know
thankfully for me uh up until this point
i mean knock on wood it's always been
you know non-material amounts i was
screwing around or whatever and learning
uh but there are definitely people who
uh on one extreme you know the guy who's
digging through the landfill trying to
find a hard drive but supposedly he's
got you know hundreds of millions of
dollars but he literally can't find it
uh to uh maybe the people who joke on
twitter and say oh i got in a boating
accident right
how do they determine whether you
actually forgot it versus you won't hand
it over like
yeah that's just gonna be that's just
gonna come down to
you know
putting putting the contemnor possible
contemporary on the stand asking them
questions and then making that determine
that credibility determination there in
in court i mean this is
yeah that is crazy it is crazy it's it's
and it's something that like
it sounds it sounds farfetched but um
like it's like it's happening i'm i'm
tracking cases where this is happening
really there was a case um
there was a case i can't remember was in
the states
but somebody
the the plaintiff accused somebody of
defrauding them out of you know bitcoin
and some other cryptocurrencies they
were in some business deal and
the defendant never paid
and so
i guess they were in the netherlands
maybe so um the plaintiff gets one of
these pre-judgment attachments
in the netherlands
wouldn't have been able to get that in
the states um it's again it's very hard
to get those wouldn't have been able to
get that in the states comes to the
states
and
what
domesticates is what it's called that
judgment and so you know we generally
our courts generally give
credit and you know full faith and
credit to foreign judgments that you
know look look like they're on the up
and up right
now you can challenge them not from not
from north korea right you can challenge
them and say there was you know your due
process was violated in that proceeding
um
so so this judgment gets domesticated
turn over the bitcoin
um
and u.s marshals actually came to this
defendant's house
to
ask him for the private keys and he gave
him the finger
i mean figuratively yeah and didn't turn
it over and so this this guy is being is
going through contempt proceedings now
in federal court for not turning over
you know i don't know anything about the
facts of the case i don't know
you know what you know whether or not
the allegations are true but that that
is an instance where the the court is
going through contempt proceedings
because someone is not turning over
private keys so
15 20 years ago you know pre-bitcoin uh
the only thing i could think of that is
anywhere similar would be like if i had
some massive safe exactly right in my
apartment or something and i had a bunch
of cash and they came and they said give
us the code and you're like i'm gonna
give you the code exactly yeah they
probably would just take the safe and
like break it open you know or whatever
like they would still crack it
eventually yeah even if uh you you
wanted to make it harder for them
this is
that on steroids right
it feels uh very different today's
episode is brought to you by ftx us
they're a safe regulated way to buy
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies they've got
very cheap fees sometimes as much as 85
percent cheaper than their competitors
there's also no minimum fees there's no
withdrawal fees or any other hidden fees
ultimately ftx us is trying to make it
dead simple for you to buy bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies they also now have
digital stock trading as well with no
transaction fees and no payment for
order flow all you have to do is go
download the ftx app today from the app
store and use code pop and you'll get
some money back every single time you
trade 10 or more again go download the
ftx app today use code pomp and every
time you trade 10 or more they'll go
ahead and they'll give you some crypto
back the more you trade the more you
earn download the ftx app today yeah um
so now so now if if we're
you know proponents of this technology
we have to acknowledge that this is not
this is an externality that
for an individual who's being wrongfully
sued
is great that i can protect my my funds
you know i had you know i've told this
story before but you know i had a client
whose
father's gold coins that she was
bequeathed and kept in the safety
deposit box
were
seized to satisfy her husband's judgment
in a case where she wasn't a defendant
and he wasn't even an account holder on
the box but he had access to the box and
so
the courts
basically conferred
yeah that you know
he had access and it belonged to him and
those coins could be used to satisfy so
for someone like that who wants to store
value
and not have it seized under the color
of law because it happens it's great
the flip side is though you know the
money judgment transfer of value to um
administer justice
is like a really important thing to
society
right before we had this system
you know it was just go to the king and
he's gonna tell you you know what the
judgment is yeah right and and like
or
or it just goes back to like you know
i have to resolve my disputes through
conflict because there's no other way
right this money judgments are a very
like you know safe orderly you know
you know they generally give process to
everyone to have facts determined and
and if you're now going to remove that
linchpin from the justice system of
being able to satisfy money judgments
through you know garnishment on
intermediaries
um where you have recalcitrant
defendants um you know it it's
it has the possibility to stymie justice
and to prevent justice so that's an
externality that we as proponents of
this technology need to acknowledge and
realize like
bitcoin doesn't fix everything fix a lot
of things
can also break some things in the
process i think you know the society we
eventually get to with mass adoption is
on the whole better but there's a lot of
growing pains between now and then
and so we should think about those
negative externalities and how to maybe
avoid them
and how how we can facilitate
systems um that that can accommodate you
know that help us get on the right path
to our you know where we're going yeah
that makes a lot of sense and um you
could see good and bad coming out of
that right yeah again it goes back to
that neutral technology that's you know
being used for good and bad
i got a question on twitter i've already
told you this question i want you to
look it up okay first uh and let me uh
put a big caveat on this uh i don't know
the individual they were uh i think i'm
pretty sure was a pseudo anonymous
account and they dm'd me and they said
uh right after the alex jones judgment
and they basically said uh
this opens a can of worms this is insane
if somebody can hold a
media publisher uh
liable for saying something that they
actually do not believe to be true
[Music]
then
their word's not mine uh essentially was
well then every media company on earth
you know should be held liable and
explicitly pointed to um i believe you
mentioned uh the hunter biden laptop
story of like somebody who is publishing
it may have thought it was really real
what they were saying it wasn't or
whatever
so uh
crazy characters involved a lot lots of
uh complexity but if we just pull out of
this for a second what was interesting
to me uh and i i didn't want to engage
too much because i didn't know who this
person was
i was like i have no idea uh but what
was fascinating was this idea of
uh free speech uh
but there's an element of like publisher
versus private individual and then um
the moving of belief and what i mean by
that is like if somebody says something
it believes it to be true and they say
it and they keep repeating it but at
some point they change their mind
then it feels like then they could
become liable which you know
however that plays out but like how do
you analyze the alex jones kind of
entire judgment
with
mainstream media and at least the
perception i think from the you know
average american being like oh they're
lying to us right
whether that's true or not you know you
could be debated but like
has the game shifted now a little bit
after this or is this just implementing
some rules
um i think what's interesting about the
i guess it's not interesting but the
alex jones
judgment is actually he actually
defaulted on
liability okay explain what that means
so
the
whether or not he was acting the court
essentially adjudicated him
libel
without him defending because
i think he was like dragging his feet on
a lot of a lot of uh discovery issues
and didn't turn over a ton of evidence
and was just stonewalling for years and
years
and eventually courts get fed up with
that because it is an obstruction of
justice essentially and um they will
default you meaning you you you're now
you're not liable liability is
determined now we just have to decide
how much you owe so he essentially
forfeited his right to defend himself
interesting on yeah definitely from a
legal proceeding standpoint
they made a claim he could have defended
himself and maybe
been victorious or not right but he just
decided for whatever reason not to do
that right he was just stonewalling so
you know that's that's an interesting
caveat to whenever we're comparing this
you know
this case to anything else is that um
liability was a foregone conclusion
based on alex jones's actions within the
litigation okay um
now
you know in terms of like just general
defamation law
right i mean there's there's a few you
know truth is a defense to defamation if
you know
opinion speech is a you know defense to
defamation because that again gets into
um
free speech right you know something
that's
you know if if i call you a you know
[ __ ] coiner that's my opinion it's not
i'm not calling you that um
so so that's
that's another defense that could have
been raised um again the
allegations and you know the statements
that were made were like
were really tough statements right that
he was making about these parents of you
know because it wasn't just about the
event i think it was also about
individuals it was about individuals
themselves
right
and attacking them when they went on you
know and gave interviews on television
as crisis actors and and things like
that
um that
would have been really hard to defend
if if i'm part of his defense team you
know
that's because like truth is a defense
so like what you're going to try and you
know
prove that this person was an actor like
you're not you're not going to do that
that was that was a lie right so
his situation uh
has a lot of emotions attached to which
right but we kind of pull away from the
emotions and we just look at it if he
had showed up to court and not
stonewalled or whatever and he was like
that was my opinion does that like
absolve him and he could have said
whatever he wanted it because it was
quote his opinion or like how does the
court look at
opinion verse like i don't care what
your opinion is you can't say certain
things yeah there's
again it gets into it's like a really
like gray area when you go into that
opinion um interesting calling someone
calling someone a crisis actor
um
[Music]
is
it seems qualitatively different than
calling someone an [ __ ]
right
you're you're because now what you're
doing is you're
um there's this like concept and
defamation law of like you know the the
reason that you're being harmed is
because your status in the community is
being denigrated
um
by that
you know presumed fact you know that
statement that's being offered as a fact
um
so
yeah it would have been a it would have
been he's in a tough situation he was in
a tough situation he would have been on
the hook uh he put him in the way
situation yeah
yeah but yeah let's be let's be clear
if i were on his defense team i would
have been
uh
if we take that a step further and we
say to ourselves okay uh one of the
things that you always hear and i think
actually elon musk tweeted about this a
couple weeks ago he was like oh it's
really hard for public figures or people
that you know that are in the news or
whatever to prove this defamation stuff
um and it was around uh the article
about him sleeping with sergey brin's
wife right right yeah and he was like
well she's not a public figure like
maybe she could go after them but like
basically you know he's a public figure
yeah
how do they determine that in the sense
of like if the parents in this situation
who i think
as far as i think everyone would analyze
they're not public figures right but
then they go on television and they're
doing interviews on national television
like
how does a court look at like what
becomes a public figure i actually don't
know the answer to that question that's
a good question i actually don't know
the answer to that it would probably
i mean i'm sure that
going to be case law dependent on
whatever jurisdiction you're in but i
you know it's probably going to be
looking at
just
general
general press coverage of somebody you
know like you just walk out on the
street right 51 or more notes and like
your boyfriend yeah that's a good that's
a good question i don't really answer
that one the reason why i think of it is
um uh it's separate from that case uh
it's almost like you know a-list
celebrity like definitely public figure
like d-list celebrity maybe not this
does get litigated like there is there
is case law out there on this like who's
who's a public vendor because that's
that you know that's one defense is like
oh no you know that plaintiff is a
public figure so you know
the the standard game on yeah it's like
it's like game on yeah um
so yeah that's uh
it's been interesting and if we go back
to the question this person asked me in
terms of like the mainstream media
they have legal teams they've compliance
you know they've got all this stuff that
they're trying to do things the right
way hopefully um
could they be held liable like if they
wrote an article saying something and
somebody else at the organization didn't
believe that thing
is that like a legal liability it can be
it's really difficult because you you
have to
it can't really be an oops
right it can't be like
you know
the the investigative team you know did
its diligence and put out this piece
and then
come to find out there was additional
information that we learned after the
fact and then you know now
probably probably the
newspaper has to retract at that point
maybe
you know there's actually a really good
movie about this set in miami with um
with uh paul newman absence of malice oh
i've not seen that yeah you should go
check it out because it's a great time
capsule of miami in like the 70s and you
look at you know i mean it's shot like
on location here and so like you know
he's living like in the bay downtown on
a boat and like there's nothing around
right yeah yeah
it's just totally wide open um but yeah
there was a movie about this and like
you know sally fields was a reporter and
like reported on like i guess his
uh
relationship to like the mob or
something like that which turned out not
to be true and like it was yeah it's an
interesting movie
and it's called absence of malice
because
you know that's
that is part of what you're looking at
uh in defamation cases when um you're
going after a a public figure or
whatever you know you've got to prove
uh or malice is actually what you don't
have to prove it's a public figure right
it's it's just uh um
[Music]
the public figure uh
actually i think i've got that backwards
but anyways it's a it's a good movie go
go check out absence of malice and when
we think about the public conversation
right media publishers are one piece of
it um
celebrities whatever another piece but
we talk on twitter
there's you know hundreds of millions of
other people on twitter yeah you've got
all the other social networks or
whatever um
one of the things
to me that feels uh the big question
mark in society is uh how comfortable is
society with those platforms
moderating speech right and
i think most people again not everyone
but most people would say hey if you go
on twitter and you're like you know i'm
going to go shoot something you know
right conduct a shooting or whatever
you're like that shouldn't be on and by
the way like law enforcement should
probably be
given a heads up and kind of addressed
if you go on and uh in march of 2020 you
say
i think that this thing may have come
from a lab right
at the time
no bueno right you're literally people
were kicked off like all this stuff now
there's politicians going on national
television talking about it right and so
if we just zoom out for a second and
with the benefit of hindsight we say to
ourselves oh facts can change right like
literally quote truth changes based on
the information we have at the time you
can also look at cdc at one point said
maths don't work then they say they work
now the new guidance
kind of is like you know everyone's good
like you know it's over um
how
do lawyers courts
platforms think about like what's true
in one moment in time
may actually not be the like consensus
truth at another time right
yeah i think your example of like you
know someone go you know making threats
and threatening speech and inciting
violence that's a pretty good like line
in the sand for a platform like yes
we're gonna we're we're gonna make sure
that you know that that's not part of
our terms and service and we're going to
moderate that content
yeah content moderation is not i mean i
i'm of the opinion that there's a lot
there's too much content moderation
going on
um
yeah there needs to be more of a free
hand um when it comes to speech at the
same time
um these are private companies um that
are running these platforms and um
you know they can they can moderate how
they how they choose to
that gets difficult that's that's where
there's a lot of pushback from people
because it's like well no they should be
treated as common carriers like you know
they're they're just the telephone wires
now of our society you know they should
be regulated like a utility and um
and then we could tweak that now the
problem with that is like you're gonna
regulate twitter like a utility
well
who's doing the regulating right like
now you've just
given the government
you know the ability to
tweak what the content moderation is
what what is the does anybody really
want that i mean some people might but
yeah well a lot of people actually
in a scary one yeah um what does the
government do with the telephones do
they give them like
again uh uh uneducated view of it would
be uh i can call you and say whatever i
want
and yeah
isn't gonna
all of a sudden shut down or you know
right my phone doesn't blow up in my
hand you know like there's nothing kind
of crazy right happens yeah but maybe
that's not true i don't know um
telephones you know there's like wire
fraud and stuff if you commit crimes
over the over the telephone you know
it's interstate wire fraud and stuff
like that but um but it's all it's after
the fact
right it goes to court right it's not
like all of a sudden that like a t or
verizon can't show up and be like we're
shutting down your service before you've
gone to court yeah i think think of it
more you know the analogy is i guess to
like uh to broadcasters and the airwaves
and stuff like that um
and and regulation of that
um
and
you know i'm not i'm not like a you know
regulatory expert when it comes to that
either i know there is
you know
the first amendment does prevent what
the government can do to to some degree
when it comes to you know allowing
like you know allowing
counter points
to be broadcast
on
but uh yeah so the first amendment still
backstops what can and can't be
regulated there um but you know
like so you know i i'm not sure
folks folks who say they want
regulation around twitter um
and and these platforms you know i think
they need to think through a little bit
more carefully you know what what that's
going to mean
um and if it's just that you don't
like being you know you don't like the
way
a platform is is
you know
preventing a certain conversation from
happening
um
again i just
i want to reiterate like you really
won't like it if the government's doing
that
i mean it's it it's now one can argue
well they essentially are captured by
the government already
um
they don't want to run afoul of the
government
um
because they're huge giant centralized
corporations that are easy targets for
regulation and anti-trust which is you
know what's what's going on yeah a lot
of noise uh on the hill about antitrust
regulation and breaking up you know
these big tech giants again yeah um
so
yeah it's how true this is but um
i saw
a screenshot which again you know i hope
it wasn't fabricated um there's a
screenshot where uh
are you familiar with this guy alex uh
berenson i think i said you say his name
um he sounds familiar he he was one of
the
probably the loudest voice questioning
uh the response to kovid okay uh at
least one of them and uh
the screenshot was notes or
communication uh inside of twitter after
they had visited some politicians in
washington dc
and it was and i'm paraphrasing but
basically something is effective like
you know meeting went well uh their main
sticking point was like they were asking
why alex bernstein has been kicked off
twitter yet and so
it kind of shocked me a little bit like
yeah you don't get to see these
communications every day obviously
there's some lawsuit or something where
they they probably get made public
but that was like a question like hold
on a second here
like we have a government official it's
unclear who government or whatever
but some somebody in the government you
know apparatus
asking a private company about it now
what didn't appear to be the claim was
they were demanding kick them off
explicitly right
implicitly
right if you're asking about one of the
330 million people who happen to use the
service or you know whatever the numbers
are um
how does that play like
right is that that's normal i oh i don't
know but you know that's an example of
like well maybe maybe if maybe if it
were all out you know the regulation
we're all out in the open
it would be better than this backdoor
regulation that may or may not be
going on i mean look we know there's a
lot of interfacing
you know back channel interfacing that
happens
um i don't know it's it's a huge i don't
have the answers it's a huge huge issue
um
you know
yeah
society needs to be able to communicate
freely
uh with each other at the same time um
you know
companies should be allowed to make
decisions you know for themselves
um
i mean that's
that's uh
actually there's a case going on here in
florida uh
right now with the like anti-woke
legislation okay that was passed um
where
a judge i think it was maybe in the
northern district of florida but here a
federal judge here in florida enjoined
part of the legislation that
prevented private companies here in
florida from
uh requiring like dei trainings like
diversity equity inclusion the
government said you cannot require this
yes the state of florida said here's a
list
of essentially viewpoints
that that were essentially like you know
white fragility type talking points
that
you are not allowed to make it a
requirement
that doesn't mean you can't do it just
means you can't require it of yours of
your impact i don't know
i think it was pretty it was pretty
broad that's what the
opinion said it was pretty pretty broad
um and enjoined
enforcement of this saying like look now
private companies need to be able it's
free speech private companies
should be able to you know hire folks
and as a requirement you know have them
go to whatever training
that person doesn't like that training
they don't have to stay at that job like
you know um so that's that's an example
of where you know
content the government's now engaging in
content moderation or was trying to
state of florida um
on private companies
um
and you know the first amendment still
prevents that
you know the government can't
can't regulate viewpoints um and so
you know forcing twitter to
offer viewpoints um i think that's i
think that's still a violation of the
first amendment if you're gonna
regulate twitter and force them to air
you know
viewpoints that they wouldn't
air themselves
brings up it's weird because we're
talking about twitter which is a huge
faceless corporation yeah but
corporations have speech rights too yeah
it's um on all the platforms they do
this now uh but
we talk about all kinds of stuff on this
show uh
spotify and youtube are the two biggest
ones where i see it
they will put these labels
into the content yeah i've seen these
and it's usually it's like a covid learn
about code 19 or something always learn
about it which is always weird because
then i'll listen to like that podcast
and it literally has nothing to do with
i almost think it's like random it's
something well here's something so i
don't know
you know there's algorithms there's two
things that i'll i'll uh i'll tell you
that i've noticed recently and then i'll
tell you a story when i worked at
facebook okay that will uh uh i think
give people more context yeah into
working so that's the content conversion
so uh if we mention the word covet
spotify youtube bam you're getting the
the label uh
there are audiences where when they see
the label like oh this is gonna be good
right right
marketing uh not saying that's good or
bad i'm just saying like i've seen the
comments and for sure people like oh
[ __ ] you got the label i'm definitely
listening um which like it's some weird
like counterclockwise like the black
flag yeah like just like some weird uh
thing that comes out of stuff
but
uh also
uh guess what the one topic is that
without fail
gets suppressed
like it it's so egregious now that it's
impossible to ignore i have no idea not
the virus
china
really
we put a video up really it's like a
joke now right it's like what are they
what are they labeling it there's no
labels it's just you can just see it
just goes into it regular content has
like kind of an average you know
velocity and all this stuff it's the
shadow shadow banning type thing yeah
and
i'm sure that there are
explanations whether i agree with them
or not or what you know whatever and all
stuff uh but it's fascinating to watch
like yeah you know when you create a lot
of content on the internet i think you
pretty much know uh hey if i post this
it'll be popular if i post this it won't
be popular right
yeah you've got a baseline now and
there's certain words that just you know
that they're going to get treated
differently and so what does it change
the way the content gets created right
because then people start to like joke
like maybe we should talk about
self-censorship and every time it comes
up we'll just bleep it yeah
everyone knows it but like
we have not done that
but when i was at facebook uh um i uh so
i'd been in the military i was working
at facebook um and i worked on the
facebook pages team okay uh and we had a
job to grow the pages all stuff but it
was a very kind of uh uh unique position
because the pages was like the top of
the funnel for their business product
okay so you got a page to be an
advertiser yeah revenue like old stuff
and so you'd meet a lot of people around
the company and i remember i met a
gentleman
and uh i can't remember if he reached
out to me or somebody introduced
whatever uh and he was on the uh he was
on a different team but part of what he
did was he was very interested in
content moderation specifically around
um uh
specific groups from the middle east uh
that had uh either been labeled as
terrorist organizations or
were questionable
i remember talking this guy and he was
like you have no clue like a video come
out and it's like it spreads like
freaking wildfire right and it's not
just one account it's uploaded to
hundreds of thousands of accounts
somewhere being like an interesting data
point
as it is you know three four weeks later
a video comes out and uh i don't want to
describe it in too much detail but
basically it was uh they'd capture they
allegedly had captured a pilot
uh
and they basically burned them and it
was all on video and it was done in like
a very uh almost like a high school
football highlight table right and
there's music and this and it was just
so grotesque yeah
it got uploaded
and there was an internal thing and i
saw i got uploaded and i went clicked on
it
and i remember being like man i seen
some crazy [ __ ] in my life
is bad
and it was just getting uploaded over
and over and over and over and over uh
just all over the place and they had
systems internally to try to you know
whether it's something about the video
and the metadata or whatever and just
try to identify it and take it down take
it down take it down
it was impossible
right just because it's just the scale
of
billions of users
one video being replicated over and over
again just all this stuff and i remember
for the first time being like
oh man if there was no moderation like
there was if there was nothing and it
was like completely wild west
you know like you wouldn't go on twitter
yeah right because the videos that would
end up getting so much engagement and
all stuff would be the most extreme
things that yeah well that brings up an
interesting question right like
because of the
the sheer
number and size of you know the sheer
quantity of content
that is
that is available now on the internet
you know back in the 90s it was like you
were on chat
you know
rooms and message boards and you know
there wasn't there wasn't that many
people on the internet it was like 40
million people or something like that
like in the 90s like it wasn't more
people using bitcoin yeah that's right
that's right absolutely like that's
where we are like um
and so you know the necessity
such that there is one and here it
sounds like this there absolutely was a
necessity for content moderation
especially when you're talking about
right violent
and it was like not just violence it was
everyone else should go conduct violence
right right um you know the need for
that kind of moderation wasn't wasn't
his
nobody was
you could avoid the content let's put it
that way
you knew you you knew to like you know
unsubscribe from that list serve you
know if too much of that stuff came up
and like you could
avoid it i guess
and now it's it's you know with
you know billions of people on the
internet and on these platforms it's
hard to avoid uh content um well if you
think that just the news feed right i
mean the invention of the news feed
itself of uh if you were on myspace and
i went to your profile right okay i had
navigated there or whatever but the
invention of like let's take all this
content let's put it into one specific
location and let's start to
algorithmically rank it
uh okay still that's like people that i
somehow have connected with right
whether i friended them on page whatever
but then you get share on a facebook or
a retweet on twitter and now
technically yes if you reach retweet
something i followed you
but the velocity at which this
information can spread is drastically
different yeah than
you know if you had to copy and paste it
and go and like it's just different yeah
and so then you also get into things
like i don't know if you've seen on
uh instagram does this a lot uh it's
like they'll show you a post
and they'll have a little thing at the
top and it'll be like uh you're seeing
this because you follow this account
yeah yeah you know like
something every once when i'm like oh
like
good you know good new account you know
that's what i'm like this is kind of
weird it's the reason i quit instagram
actually among many other reasons but
yeah i just felt it felt like i was just
grist in their advertising mill yeah and
it was and it sucked because like i
liked you know like i'm a photographer
like amateur photographer and so like i
followed you know just photographers
basically and like that was you know
accounts that had you know good artistic
marriage they love you guys yeah the
camera advertisers that's right that's
right um and uh and but it was just like
yeah it was too much over and over it
was too in your face and so now you know
so applaud them for putting that out
there and saying like you know hey
you're seeing this because because then
i was able to make a decision to not use
the service anymore but
so we'll see how long they keep doing
that yes um yeah and i don't know if
that's something that um
you know that that congress wants to do
i mean you know and i know they've been
holding tons of hearings on you know the
algorithms
and mental health and social media and
um
you know eventually i guess congress is
just going to have to try and
you know pull the trigger and pass
something to regulate
and then we'll work it out it's weird
like it like it's classic uh
grandstanding to some degree oh for sure
it's always like this um
uh
i have a nine-month-old daughter right
so like uh when i see the hearings and
they're like teenage girls mental health
i'm like by the way
yes
but so is the 65 year old man who's on
the same platform like they're getting
the same garbage as well right and like
sure i get like one is you know
self-image and body and and you're in a
kind of malleable part of your life and
like so there there's a difference to a
degree
but in some way it's like no this is
like a humanity thing yeah right if you
sit and you just doom scroll all day
long like that's going to happen
it has it has a serious effect on
people's mental health it's tough yeah
and people people are not designed to
have this like constant feed of
information about the world all the time
right right like we're we're not
omniscient like we you know we we
developed and we evolved in these like
tiny little communities
right where it was like
your relation you could like max out
your relationship to like a hundred
right or something like that i think
there's been some like studies about you
know networks yes stuff and you know
basically like yeah individual humans
yeah top out like we've got so many yeah
where you can really like service them
and you know and know each other well
and and and create a society around that
um without some kind of scaling solution
so we're just not we're not meant to to
have all this information but here it is
i've noticed a uh
a trend in communication that maybe i
wasn't paying attention before or
whatever but i now regularly get emails
and people will say you know hi pomp
and then there's some qualifier as to
how i know them what they do or where we
met
and then they whatever the email is
about
and like i'm sure that you know if uh if
i walked up to somebody randomly on the
street 20 years ago or something right
and we started talking i said oh
remember we met yeah whatever right so
so it's not that like this is some brand
new thing right but it's almost like
there's this expectation that the people
you communicate with actually may not
remember you or whatever and it feels
like that is uh sad in a way but it's
just the nature of like you know how
many emails do you get how many people
on social media like like you can't keep
track of everyone right and especially
if you haven't met these people face to
face then you don't so now i ask myself
like damn i started off emails it was
like
you know what it is
uh but but it does it does change the
way that people communicate and interact
and
i don't know it's just a weird
freaking thing yeah and i don't i don't
know what the answer is um
and and but it's but look like the
conversation needs to be had and uh you
know i think ultimately the answer is
going back to
um
you know the internet and avoiding
content and stuff like as long as
as long as they're you know there are
forums and places where people can go to
find
the content that is not mainstream and
that is being suppressed by these
platforms like the alternate
forums exist
um
[Music]
and maybe one day those alternate forums
and the ideas on those alternate forums
um
catch
you know more mainstream
you know uh acceptance and then
it shifts and the bigger platforms are
now you know just like you were saying
with hunter biden's laptop and
you know the the lab leak theory stuff
um you know but as long as there's
as long as there is a forum somewhere
for ideas um
you know
maybe that's the answer as long as
you're not totally suppressing every
forum um and and you know there's
there's there was gab and there's truth
social and
you know there's you know fortran 4chan
and 8chan and 12chan and whatever chan
it's up to now like you know those like
you know kind of seedy parts of the
internet if you want to call it that
um
exist where you know those
non-mainstream ideas can be discussed um
as you know distasteful as the
mainstream finds them or you and i would
find them um the fact that they exist
that's that that's good and that should
be there's a market for it and you know
even if it's small
um and so yeah because you
battling network effects is hard yeah
battling network effects is hard and
it's it's really hard even when you know
it when it's a level playing field
and then when the network you know the
owner of the network is you know using
that network
you know it's yeah it's tough it's tough
to beat
so
the place i want to uh end on um
you spend a bunch of time first
amendment uh many other legal issues but
uh if somebody wants to go learn more
about the first amendment and kind of
how it's uh its role in today's like
modern society uh i'll give one
suggestion and then i'd love to hear
from you where they can go uh mine is
just go read the first amendment yeah
like i'm always surprised like by the
way i don't have it memorized or
anything like you don't have to be like
you know an expert on it but like
literally just go read it one time so
you know what's in there it's probably a
good starting point but are there other
places that you would suggest people to
go and get educated or things that you
feel like are good resources or anything
um
let's see um
start definitely start with uh with the
first amendment and read that it's not
going to give you too much uh clarity
though you know as
there are lots of provisions of the
constitution that uh you know we don't
have much clarity on and and then you
know funny
funny story real quick about that is you
know i have like little pocket
constitutions that i keep around the
house and you know my my son i took it
to like show and tell one time for like
you know
it was like a memorial day or something
like that something something about
america and then i also have like my law
books and like some treatises from law
school stuff and these are like you know
a thousand pages and like 10 times the
size of the pocket constitution and you
know my son son was like oh that's
that's the constitution too i was like
well
yeah that's everybody fighting over what
that little book and those little words
mean is is right here so
um it's a great way to look at it yeah
there there are tons of treatises you
can go and look at that's probably too
high level you know
if you're interest if you're coming at
it from a perspective from you know like
a digital assets perspective um
coin center has a lot of great
explainers if you just go to their
website they have a lot of educational
material and they've put out some really
good
analysis of like um dexa's decentralized
exchanges and the first amendment um
i i would suggest just checking that out
and see what peter van valkenberg and um
jerry burrito written over there because
they they're pretty good at laying
things out laying out the um the
relevant doctrines first amendment
doctrines that apply to digital assets
that's a that's a good place to start
awesome uh and then for you and in your
practice like what do you specialize in
or if folks want to reach out where can
they yeah so i'm um a pellet attorney
which means uh whenever there's an
appeal of a
judgment or an order you want to reverse
it or uphold it
that's where i get involved and
sometimes i'm involved earlier during
the litigation we're anticipating you
know appeals
[Music]
so that's i do a lot of briefing and
researching and writing and that's you
know kind of kind of where i came into
bitcoin and digital assets is i've now
started to write and research on issues
like the first amendment
um that intersect with with bitcoin
um and so you can you can find me at
bitcoinbrief.io
is my newsletter my legal research
newsletter where i cover a lot of these
topics
i've written some pieces for bitcoin
magazine uh if you just go to like their
search author page you can find it um
i'm on twitter uh at wa daniel
uh and if you go to like florida bar's
website put in my my name william aaron
daniel
myself you know i'm out there i'm uh you
know here's my face you can find my
office call my office
yeah
i uh uh i i do love a good uh a good
person to come up to me uh in some
social setting and say like i'm so and
so on twitter yeah and my wife always
laughs she's like it's always like you
know like crypto panda
right right right you're like
how'd you go with that name man yeah no
again nems are important yeah it's you
know we've been bashing twitter a little
bit but it's great that twitter is still
you know twitter
platform yeah uh
one of the most important platforms for
sure in america uh i would argue that
for most people or many of the people
who are listening to this from a
business professional career standpoint
twitter is what linkedin should have
been yeah which is like that's where you
actually go meet people right and you
have connections you have conversations
yeah yeah and and it's like cool you
know yes the whole like linkedin profile
of like what have you done in your
career is like cool um
but the social aspect's so powerful it
is it's it's really powerful and it's
again because
because you get to stay anonymous if you
choose to on twitter i mean that's
that's i i understand it creates a lot
of bots you know and we've got a big
problem that was less than five percent
yeah that's what that's what elon was
was he was getting you know being his
body about was all the bots and and uh
but you know it's it's important that
we're allowed to have the option to go
into these space these public spaces and
have these debates you know anonymously
just like our founders did right you
know they they were able to publish
anonymously and have these really
important debates about the direction of
our country and the structure of our
government
anonymously so that you know their
personalities you know they were they
were public figures some of them their
personalities didn't bias people to the
message they were hearing uh so they
didn't get you know backlash um it's
it's important that we have these these
anonymous channels yeah
uh yeah i appreciate your time this is a
fantastic thanks for having me i feel
like i got a crash course and uh uh my
conclusion on many of these things is
like they are way more complex than
people on the surface realize yeah um
and you know and things like tornado
cash we're going to wait to get a lot
more information before we kind of
understand how to play out but uh
it's concerning times but at the same
time i think it's uh you know important
people educate themselves so that uh
they they are informed in terms of how
uh the direction of this stuff goes
exactly couldn't agree more